definamos una variable aleatoria x
mayúscula como el número de soles que
salen en tres volados de una moneda
justa y lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es graficar la función de masa de
probabilidad de esta variable aleatoria
y esa función de masa de probabilidad es
la que nos dice cómo se distribuye la
probabilidad a lo largo de todos los
posibles resultados de esta variable
aleatoria entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar cuáles son todos los
posibles resultados de este experimento
y calcular cuál es la probabilidad de
cada uno de esos posibles resultados
entonces cuáles son los posibles
resultados de este experimento de lanzar
tres volados de una moneda justa pues se
puede salir sol sol sol o te puede salir
sol sol águila o sol águila sol o sol
águila águila o también nos puede salir
aquí
sol sol águila águila sol águila sol
águila o águila águila y águila aunque
bueno en algunos países las monedas no
son de águila o sol a veces tienen caras
o cruces pero en este vídeo por lo menos
tenemos sol o águila pero bueno el
chiste es que si hacemos este
experimento de lanzar tres volados
podemos obtener cualquiera de estos ocho
resultados y además cada uno de estos
resultados tienen la misma probabilidad
de ocurrir entonces decimos que tenemos
ocho resultados
ec y probables ahora como se relaciona
todo esto con los valores que puede
llegar a tomar la variable x pues
pensemos en cuál es la probabilidad de
que la variable x sea igual a cero
entonces para que la variable x sea
igual a cero necesitamos que el número
de soles en nuestros tres volados sea
cero o sea que no salga ni
un solo sol en los tres volados y aquí
tenemos el resultado de los tres volados
en el cual no tenemos ni un solo sol
entonces de los ocho resultados ec y
probables solo uno de ellos hace que la
variable x sea igual a cero entonces la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a cero
es 1 entre 8 ahora cuál es la
probabilidad de que la variable x sea
igual a 1 pues para que la variable x
sea igual a 1 necesitamos que en total
haya un sol y en este resultado hay un
sol en este otro resultado también hay
un sol
en este otro resultado también hay un
sol y es el único que nos faltaba
entonces de los ocho equipos hables
resultados tres de ellos tienen
exactamente un sol y por lo tanto hacen
que la variable x sea igual a 1 entonces
la probabilidad es igual a 3 entre 8
ahora vamos a ver cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 2 y me
imagino que ya tienes una muy buena idea
de cómo funciona esto a ver para que x
sea igual a 2 tiene que haber dos soles
este es un resultado que tiene dos soles
este es otro resultado del experimento
que tiene dos soles y este es el otro
resultado que tiene dos soles entonces
son tres experimentos tres experimentos
de ocho posibles resultados x probables
entre 8 y
esta es la probabilidad ahora cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3 pues
el único resultado del experimento en el
que salen 3 soles es este así es que la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3 es 1
entre 8 y listo ahora lo único que nos
falta es graficar estas probabilidades
para ver realmente cómo se distribuye la
probabilidad y cómo se ve la función de
masa de probabilidad entonces pues vamos
a graficar la tenemos por aquí el eje de
las leyes y por aquí tenemos el eje de
las x en el eje de las yes vamos a
escribir la probabilidad
probabilidad la cual está siempre entre
0 y 1 ahora todas estas prueba billy
bebés están en octavos entonces de una
vez vamos a poner aquí todos los octavos
si este es el 1 entonces más o menos por
aquí está la mitad y vamos a poner los
cuartos y ahora los octavos
bueno más o menos nos quedó ahora lo que
tenemos que poner en este otro eje son
los resultados resultados los posibles
resultados de estos tres volados que son
0 1 2 y 3 aunque la verdad la verdad
creo que resultados no es la palabra
correcta lo que queremos poner aquí son
los valores de x
valores
a flores
de equis y los posibles valores que
puede tomar x son 0 0 también puede
tomar el valor 1 1
el valor 22 o el valor 3
y entonces tenemos que la probabilidad
de que x toma el valor cero es un octavo
así es que por aquí está el un octavo
vamos a ponerlo por aquí todo esto es la
probabilidad de que x tome el valor cero
vamos a rellenarlo bien y luego la
probabilidad de que x toma el valor de
uno eso es tres octavos lo cual es a
esta altura tres octavos tac tac tac tac
tac tac tac
esta es la probabilidad de que existan
el valor de uno
esta es la probabilidad de que tomo el
valor de 1 ahora la probabilidad de que
x tomo el valor de 2 es también tres
octavos o sea a esta misma altura así es
que todo esto es la probabilidad de que
x tome el valor de 2 todo esto de aquí
y finalmente la probabilidad de que x
sea igual a 3 es un octavo así es que
estamos otra vez a esta altura
esta es la probabilidad de que edificio
igual a 3 esta es la probabilidad y ya
terminemos esta es la gráfica de la
función de mazo de probabilidad estos
son todos los posibles valores que puede
tomar x x no puede tomar el valor de un
medio y puede tomar el valor de raíz de
2 ni de pi x sólo puede tomar estos 4
valores aunque ninguno de los valores
que están en medio entonces x es una
variable aleatoria discreta
creta y lo que tenemos aquí lo que
construimos en este vídeo es la función
de masa de probabilidad de una variable
aleatoria discreta
full
de más
de probabilidad
family la
de la variable discreta x